Дзвіниці Софійського собору та Києво-Печерської Лаври.
Пам'ятник Володимиру Великому та Володимирський собор.
Перлини, які притягують до Києва мільйони туристів,
виявляється, збудували за проектами німців.
Ігор Винниченко - історик-дослідник. Не один десяток років
вивчає вклад німців в українську культуру, зокрема й в архітектуру Києва.
Свою екскурсію для DW починає, так би мовити, з найрезонаснішого:
до побудови двох столичних об'єктів, які входять до світової спадщини ЮНЕСКО,
причетний німецький архітектор. Це уродженець містечка Вандсбек
(нині район Гамбурга) - Йоганн-Ґоттфрід Шедель.
Він поєднував риси класичної архітектури з українським бароко,
І йому приписують, що він один із тих, хто вдало це робив.
Шедель розробив перший варіант проєкту великої дзвіниці Успенського собору.
Замість п’ятиярусної дзвіниці звів чотири яруси, але при цьому
збільшив висоту до 96,5 метрів, тож на початку вісімнадцятого століття
це була найвища кам'яна споруда на території всієї Російської імперії.
Коли він розписувався у відомстві за отримання гонорару,
він так і написав: "Тебе, величаве творіння моє, згадуватимуть нащадки".
Тому й не дивно, що коли після землетрусу постраждала дзвіниця Софійського собору,
відновлювати покликали того ж Шеделя. Німець спершу розібрав,
а потім заново збудував другий і третій яруси дзвіниці.
Останній, четвертий ярус, звели вже в 19-му столітті.
Відтоді дзвіниця Софії - найупізнаваніша пам'ятка столиці.
Це й не дивно, адже звідси відкривається неймовірна панорама на історичний Київ.
Далі рушаємо в бік будівлі Національної Опери.
Непримітна табличка на фасаді вказує на автора будівлі - німця Віктора-Йоганна Шретера.
У 1897 році Міська дума оголосила міжнародний конкурс на проєкт будівлі Київської опери.
Проєкт Шретера, який поєднав класичний стиль і так званий "віденський модерн",
обійшов інших двадцятьох конкурсантів. Будівлю звели за 4 роки і вже в 1901 році
її урочисто відкрили виставою Михайла Глінки.
Та цікаво, що на цьому ж місці до того стояв інший театр: дерев'яний.
Звів його також німець - Йоганн або ж Іван Штром.
Німці, які жили в Російській імперії, ніколи не могли називатись так.
Фрідріх Фрідріхович ставав Федором Федоровичем, Йоганн - Іваном і так далі.
Їх просто не могли інакше записувати. Хтось, може, й не хотів записуватись.
Іншого німця Ґеорґа або Георгія Шлейфера можна впевнено назвати
впливовим забудовником української столиці наприкінці 19-го століття.
Він був головою будівничої̈ комісії̈ Думи і без його дозволу
в місті не зводилася жодна споруда. Шлейфер став автором планування
чотирьох вулиць у центрі Києва, а одну з них - Ольгинська - назвав на честь дружини.
Із вражаючою на той час швидкістю зводилися будинки на цих вулицях.
Це колишня будівля готелю "Континенталь". Тепер -
навчальний корпус Національної музичної академії імені Чайковського.
Театр Соловцова - тепер театр імені Івана Франка.
За заслуги Шлейфер навіть отримав у постійне користування особисту ложу в новому театрі.
Розповідаючи про архітектурну спадщину німців у Києві,
не можна не згадати й ім'я Карла Фрідріха Шимана.
Історик Ігор Винниченко називає його "батьком" так званих
прибуткових садибних та житлових будинків Києва.
Їх дуже багато було в Києві - прибуткових будинків. Людям було вигідно,
це як на Заході, люди не купують будинок, а знімають житло,
і їм це дешевше обходиться. Якщо своє житло, то треба комуналку сплачувати,
а тут - тільки оренду сплачуєш і все...
У прибуткових будинках жили сім'ями тривалий час професори університетів.
Мабуть, найвідоміше та найвеличніше з творінь Шимана -
будинок на розі  Володимирської та Прорізної.
Останні 20 років тут триває реконструкція, яка ніяк не завершиться.
А в минулому столітті тут кипіло життя: на першому поверсі в кафе "Маркіз",
а згодом у ресторані "Лейпциг" на ранкову каву зустрічалася київська еліта.
Також одну з туристичних візитівок Києва -
пам'ятник Володимиру Великому - можна назвати "німецьким".
До створення цього пам'ятника причетні троє німців.
У майстерні Клодта фон Юргенсбурга було відлито цю статую,
а до постамента причетні ще двоє людей з німецьким корінням:
це Костянтин Том... і Демок Малиновський.
Ось на цьому хресті були раніше свічки, а потім лампочки.
Його було видно на великій відстані.
Цікаво, що будівництво цього пам’ятника викликало спротив
тогочасного митрополита Філарета. Адже встановлення "ідола"
- пам'ятника - борцеві з ідолопоклонінням церква називала блюзнірством.
Утім, погодилася, коли влада запропонувала компроміс: киянам - пам’ятник,
а Філарету затвердили лобійований ним проєкт будівництва Володимирського собору.
Тут теж не обійшлося без німецького слІду,
адже перший проєкт Володимирського собору належить вже згаданому Івану Штрому.
Цивілізоване суспільство має вшановувати тих,
хто на це заслуговує. Якщо люди дивляться на це,
а потім виявляється, що це не українець, а німець збудував, це ж теж, мабуть, цікаво.
Місто - це поєднання багатьох культур.
Я не кажу, що це німецька культура, бо... це не готика.
Готика - це Миколаївський собор абощо.
Але якщо це німець, або єврей, або поляк зробив, то треба віддати йому належне.
Ігор Винниченко написав путівник "Німецькі адреси Києва" і вірить,
що такі маршрути будуть користуватися популярністю не лише іноземних туристів,
але й гостей та жителів міста, адже чимало нового можна побачити
на вже протоптаних маршрутах, якщо просто подивитися на них під новим кутом зору.
Приміром, німецьким.